نشير الى هذه الصور المباشره الخاصه بقناه
الجزيره وحصلت عليها قناه الجزيره وهي
مشاهد حصريه لعناصر من سرايا القدس اثناء
عمليه تجهيز منصات اطلاق صواريخ بعيده
المدى وقالت السرايا للجزيره ان رد
المقاومه على عمليه الاغتيال الاخيره بحق
القائد علي غالي قادم اذا الرد على اغتيال
القائد في سرايا القدس علي غالي قادم هذا
ما تقوله اذن فصائل المقاومه علي غالي
القائد في سرايا القدس الذي اغتيل فجر هذا
اليوم في خان يونس
واذا يجري التجهيز للرد على اغتياله كما
رده فصائل المقاومه اذن على اغتيال القاده
الثلاثه في سرايا القدس الذين اغتالتهم
اسرائيل فجره الثلاثاء
وهو ما فتح جوله التصعيد المستمره حتى
الان اذا رد المقاومه على عمليه الاغتيال
الاخيره بحق القائد علي غالي قادم تقول
سرايا القدس للجزيره مع هذه الصور اذا
الحصريه التي حصلت عليها الجزيره لعناصر
من سرايا القدس العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي اثناء تجهيز منصات اطلاق صواريخ
بعيده المدى
[موسيقى]
طبعا بينما نستمر اذا في مشاهده هذه الصور
الحصريه التي حصلت عليها الجزيره من سرايا
القدس
وتصريح الاخيره بان الرد على اغتيال
القائد علي غالق قادم